[APPLAUSE]
NICK: Hello.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you very much for
coming to this talk, "A Window
into Transitions."
It's one of the last talks
of I/O, or the ultimate talk,
if you will.
My name is Nick [? Butcher ?].
I'm joined by my colleagues
Ben [? Vice ?] and George
[? Mount. ?] We're engineers
on the developer relations
and Android engineering team.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're here today to talk
about the Android transitions
API.
We've got a lot to
cover, so we're just
going to jump straight into
the topic and get going.
So first up, transitions.
What are they?
The basic idea of
the transitions API
is to help you whenever there's
a change in the scene, where
a scene is basically a
view hierarchy on screen.
So the idea is that
when a scene changes,
my animation doesn't work
properly, ironically.
And we perform a transition.
So a transition
being look at what
has changed, and then
animate that difference.
So the API for the
transition is pretty simple.
It's just exactly the same.
What has changed?
Firstly, there will
be two callbacks
into your transition,
which is captureStartValues
and captureEndValues.
Passing in this object, this
transition values object,
so this object has the view.
And you can look at the view
and capture properties about it,
and save it into some kind of
map in the transitions values.
And so you do that in a start
state and the end state.
And then we'll call the
createAnimator method,
given those two states.
And you create animators
to animate the change
between those two states.
Cool.
So that's the very
basic API covered off.
There's a bunch of
transitions which
come in the Android framework,
which you can and absolutely
should use.
So let's have a quick
survey of what they are,
so you know what
these, then, primitives
that you can build with are.
The first, and a super
handy one to know about,
is the ChangeBounds transition.
So this will help
you out whenever you
are moving or resizing a view.
It will animate the top left
and bottom right properties
to help you move it around.
Crucially, this ChangeBounds
also helps suppress layouts.
So you don't want to be calling
RequestLayout repeatedly,
because that's going to
be bad for performance,
whereas ChangeBounds
will do this
in a performant way for you.
Secondly, there's
a fade transition,
which, as the name suggests,
helps fade things in and out.
So anytime an
object's visibility
changes or gets added or
removed from the hierarchy,
you can run a fade
to ease that change.
And lastly, there's
this awesome little guy
called the AutoTransition, which
will put some of those things
together.
So when a hierarchy changes, it
will fade newly-arriving things
in, it'll move and resize items
which are remaining or changing
position, and then fade out
anything which is disappearing.
Very handy.
In API21, or Lollipop,
transitions API
got a bunch of new and
exciting additions.
First up was the slides.
So you can-- and anytime
anything is entering or exiting
the scene, you can,
like, do so from an edge,
in a kind of, like,
nice, staggered manner.
And then there's a bunch
of transforms for whenever
you're changing the bounds.
So you can actually just
click the bounds of something
changing size, or if you're
doing a ChangeTransform, which
will affect the rotation
and scale of a view,
or if you're doing
an image-- say
you're changing from one scale
type to another scale type--
this will help
animate the changes
to the matrix of the image view
to change between those scales.
The transitions object itself
got some upgrades in 21.
So firstly, it got this
thing called PathMotion,
which basically
allows you to control
the movement along a path.
So here, for example, we're
looking at a transition
which is a shared element.
And then we can control the path
that it follows when it moves
from one state to the other.
Don't actually do this kind
of horrible loopy thing.
This is exaggerated for effect.
Please don't do that.
And the classes
you'll probably want
to look at when doing this
kind of control on the path
is called ArcMotion
and PatternPathMotion.
And we'll return to those later.
And lastly, the transitions
API got this new ability
to control the
propagation and epicenter.
So what these two
properties let you do
is to choreograph the
way a group of views
are going to move.
Easier shown with an example.
So in this example here,
when I click on an item,
see how the views around the
grid all move out together?
This is called an
explode transition.
But basically, by passing
in the epicenter, which
would be the view
you touched on,
you can then set
the start delays
on the other views which are
exiting, as well, in order
to have this
coordinated movement.
So these are the
kind of APIs to look
for if you're trying to
build this kind of transition
yourself.
So that's transitions.
It turns out that,
quite frequently,
when you're changing
scenes and want
to perform an animation
on those changes,
it is activity boundaries,
so when you're going
from one activity to another.
So API21 added a whole
bunch of new APIs
to help do this
kind of thing, which
we call window transitions.
There's two main types.
The first type is a
content transition.
So that's when a window
exits or a new window enters,
you have an opportunity
to run an animation
on the content coming in.
So in this example here, if
we go from the grid and we
launch into like a
details-type screen,
where we're going
to enter animation
on the views coming into
the details, where they're
sliding in from the bottom.
The second type is a
shared element transition.
So this is where--
oh, I went too far.
Go back.
Ah.
There we go.
A shared element is where,
when you tap on one view,
the element transitions
smoothly from one activity
into the second activity.
And as you just had a
sneak peek of there,
those two things aren't
mutually exclusive.
You can, of course, run a
shared element and the content
transition, as well.
So here we're sharing
a view and also sliding
in the unshared
content, as it were.
Now, a note on
shared element views,
like-- shared element
transitions, excuse me.
You can't actually share a
view between two activities.
You can't pick up an image
view from one activity
and supplant it
into the other one.
So what we do, as many
animation things--
APIs-- do is kind
of like fake it.
It will allow you to give
the appearance of that's
what's happening, while
still maintaining your either
one activity or the other.
So the way we do it is, when you
click on an image in the source
activity, we record some
information about that view.
Just [INAUDIBLE]
information like
the position and the bounds,
and a few other things.
And then we pass
that information over
to the destination activity.
So we then launch the
destination activity,
but don't show
anything just yet.
And then we lay out and
measure all the views
in the destination activity,
and work out where that shared
view wants to end up.
Then we do something
a bit sneaky.
We actually-- we
apply transforms
to the shared element
in the destination view
to kind of put it back
into the position it
was in in the source
view, and then
fade out any unshared content.
So at this point, destination
activity is launched.
It's the activity on top.
But it, you know, appears
as if you're still
in the source
activity, because it's
been transformed to appear so.
Then we simply run animations
to move the shared element back
into place, and fade back
up any unshared content.
Voila.
Looks like you've shared a view
from one activity to the other,
but it hasn't.
So this is important
to remember,
that everything happens in
the destination activity.
You're never actually changing
the view in the source
activity, other than hiding it.
So shared element and
content transitions
can run at a number of points.
So there's a kind of a life
cycle to think about here.
So when you go from one
screen to the other,
so when you call
startActivity, you
have the opportunity
to run transitions
on the exiting source activity
and on the entering destination
activity.
And then on the way
back, you can also then
animate on the return
and re-enter them.
So these are the four
points you can hook into.
And it's worth noting that these
kind of come in pairs, such
that if you were to set an
exit transition from the source
activity-- so, you
know, do something
with the views on
the way out-- well,
by default, if you don't specify
a different re-enter one,
it will just run the same
transition in reverse.
So worth bearing in mind
that's what's going on there.
So that's, in a nutshell,
what the transitions API
is trying to do.
To give you an example
of how to do it,
Ben is going to walk you through
an example application that
implements these APIs.
BEN: Thank you, Nick.
So as we saw, we had a couple
of transitions going on there.
And let's see what we're
going to [? aim at. ?] We will
have an application having a
master activity and a detail
activity.
And once you tap on one of the
items, it will move the image
and perform a couple
of other transitions.
So let's get started.
We have our app.
Before we actually got
started with the transitions,
this is what the
system gives us.
We tap on [INAUDIBLE] views,
and the detail activity
slides and fades in.
Pretty cool.
But in order to
use the transitions
API, what we want to do is
we first enable the window
activity transitions
within our app theme,
or simply inherit from theme
that material, or, as many
of you use it, AppCompat is also
inheriting from theme.material
on Lollipop and +.
So once we've got this,
we can go to the next step
and do the shared element
transition for the image view.
In order to do this, we
set a transition name
on both the starting
and the target view.
And remember, those have to be--
or should be, at least-- unique
for the view
hierarchies, in order
to avoid a couple of issues
that we will cover later on.
After we have taken
a look into this,
we need to tell the system
how to actually deal
with the shared element.
Because as we just learned,
sharing the element
is something that happens
within the receiving--
sorry, the detail activity.
So we have to tell
the system that,
at the point where we actually
started the new activity,
that a couple of
things have changed.
We do this by calling the
makeSceneTransitionAnimation,
pass it the image that we
want to share, as well as
the identifier for target view.
So the name that we
just said on that.
Pretty cool.
Pretty straightforward
and awesome to use.
After that, we add
the exiting transition
for the grid, which this is
the explode that we just saw,
which is probably
one of the things
that you should think about
if you actually want to do it,
because it can confuse users.
It can be very handy, as
well, on the other hand.
So make sure that you don't
just throw explodes in
everywhere, because it can be
not helpful, on the other hand,
as well.
So to do this, we create a
transition in the Transitions
folder called grid_exit.
And we just say
explode, and that's it
from the declaration
of the transition.
Pretty straightforward again.
We then set that in-- we then
have to declare the window exit
transition within
our homes activity--
home activity's theme.
And as we just learned, this
will be replayed, reversed,
on the way back in when the
activity does its reenter
transition, when we press
back from the detail activity.
Let's go and take the next step.
For the detail activity,
we also want the content
that is not shared to be slide--
to slide in from the bottom.
You don't just-- you can't
just create the transitions
from XML, but you also can
do this directly within code.
So let's take a look
at how you can do that.
We just created a
new slide transition.
We want to slide--
to have the content
slide in from the bottom.
And we want to have
it enter at full speed
and then ease in all
the way up until it
reaches its resting point.
To do this, we inflate
an interpolator
to do exactly that.
Then on the window of
[INAUDIBLE] activity,
we set the enter
transition to be
the transition we just created.
This can be a lot more complex
than this if you want to,
but to get started, just
adding one transition, seeing
if you actually got the
right things in place,
works pretty well.
Since we are already
in the motion
of getting things feel more
natural by having them enter
very quickly, let's take
a look at another thing
that Nick already mentioned.
It's curved motion.
So usually, you have
just one linear motion
of the shared element view.
But we want to have
this motion in the end
so that it fills
while you grow--
while the view is
growing, it should also
have a curved path
that it follows
to make it feel more natural.
Let's take a look at one of the
transitions that we use there.
We have a transition
set which is
a-- which is a collection
of different transitions
that will be run at a
point in the animation.
And we basically just have
to do this on the SetBounds.
We just say we want to
add an ArcMotion to that.
Pretty straightforward
again, and it
helps to get exactly this done.
You can also set
maximum, minimum angles
on that to make sure
that the user actually
sees what's going on.
You shouldn't exaggerate,
like Nick earlier said.
So but for development purposes,
this can be pretty handy.
So those are all
built-in transitions.
Let's take a look
at a thing that we
can do with getting
into custom transitions.
We also want to share
the detail text.
So the title-- this is
the author of the picture.
And we did a couple of
things there other than just
going-- just sharing that.
We also grow it.
And to do this, from the
declaration point of view,
we just go back to the
transition that we already had,
add another transition--
add a target
to both of the transitions to
have the initial transition set
only target the photo
that we already shared.
Then, we go and add
a second transition
set targeting the author that
we want to share, as well.
And add a TextResize
transition to that,
which is a custom
transition that George
will cover in a minute.
And then, of course,
we need to tell
the system what's going on,
that things have changed.
So far, we changed-- we shared
the image and the target
directly.
If you only have
one shared element,
this is the right--
this is a good way
to actually get started with
that, to share this information
with the detail activity.
If you have multiple
shared elements,
though, you want to
have pairs, which can
be created in separate ways.
But this is one of the ways.
We just create a
pair which basically
contains the same information.
It contains the detail view--
the starting view, as well
as the target transition name.
And then, instead of
having this on here,
you just pass those
two pairs in here
and start your activity as is.
And after all this is done,
this is the nice transition
set you get.
And with that, let's take
a look behind the curtain.
GEORGE: All right.
How's that firehose, everyone?
Good?
Let's drink some more.
All right, let's
talk about some--
making your own transitions.
We saw the built-in
ones-- ChangeBounds,
ChangeTransform, those ones.
Those are great
basic transitions,
but if you want to change
the text size, for example,
it's not built in.
We have to do that ourselves.
So let's see how we
go about making it.
Let's make this resize
text transition.
All right.
So we need to capture
some data, right?
And we need, of
course, the font size.
That's obvious, right?
We need to capture the
font size at the beginning,
capture the font
size at the end.
And we also need
some other data.
But when we return the
data set that we're
going to track in
our transition,
we only want-- we only
care about the font size.
Because if the
other stuff changes,
like if the bounds changes
only on your text view,
we're not going to do
any transition on that.
We're only transitioning
when the text size changes.
So we just ignore
the rest of the data.
We still want to capture it.
So that's why we have those
pieces of information,
that tag that we're going to
use in our transition values.
But we just don't want to keep
that for the transition API--
for the transition framework.
So when we capture our start
values and end values--
you remember this from what Nick
said-- we want to capture them,
and we said this
is the same thing
in both the start and the end.
We have a common function to do.
And first thing we have to do is
we can just throw away anything
that's not a text view, right?
We're only animating text views.
So anything else,
we just ignore.
Of course, we want to capture
the font size and the text size
here.
And we also want to
capture some other data.
And I just stuck this all
in its own class and kind
of hide that information.
But it's basic things like
the bounds of the text view,
because we're going to need
that for the animation.
All right.
When you animate
text, what do we do?
Are we going to
animate the font size?
Well if we do that, we're
going to thrash our font cache,
right?
Every font size between
the start and the end
is going to be used and
created in our font cache,
and we're going to have,
like, font size 26.281.
And you know, we're never
going to use that again.
It's just going to
thrash our font cache.
We don't want to do that.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to capture a bitmap at the
start and a bitmap at the end,
and we're going to animate.
So here, if we animate
just the start,
it looks pretty terrible, right?
You see that thing blown
up from the beginning.
And also, if you animate just
from the large size down,
you're going to end up with
a little bit of kerning
error in the final text view.
And you might not see
it here on this slide,
but you're definitely
going to see it when
you're looking at the phone.
And you really don't
want to see your user--
users to see that effect.
You want to see a
perfect transition.
So instead of this,
what we're going to do
is we're going to
animate piecewise.
So we animate a little
bit from the start.
And you don't really see
that blown-up image, right?
And then we're
going to swap it out
for the final image,
just scaled down.
And then we're going to
animate the rest of the way.
And because it's done
during the motion,
nobody will see that
animation, that change,
that swap there in the middle.
OK?
Let's see how we do that.
When we create our animator,
first thing we have to do,
of course, is to capture-- we
use our start values and end
values.
But here, we are checking the
start values if they're null.
What does null mean?
It means the view didn't exist.
So if the view didn't exist at
the beginning or at the end,
we don't want to animate size.
That's for fade, right?
That's for the
other transitions.
OK?
Next thing we have
to do, of course,
is capture the
start bitmap, right?
So we just capture that bitmap.
That's where that
extra data is useful.
And we also have to capture
the end state bitmap.
And then, of course, we have
to say, don't-- text view,
don't draw yourself.
Set yourself to transparent.
All that text stuff,
make it transparent.
We don't want you to draw it.
Because what we're going to do
is create a drawable with those
bitmaps that we just
captured that's going
to do the swapping for us.
All right.
So we need to animate some
things on that drawable.
One of them is the font size.
We're going to have this
font size that we're going
to animate on the drawable.
And we also have to
animate those other things,
all that other data I captured.
But we need to know that stuff.
So we get property
values holders for those,
and then we create
the animator, right?
And then we're all
set to return, right?
Everyone?
Not quite.
Remember what we just did?
We set it to be invisible?
Like no, don't draw that text?
When the animation
is done, we want it
to go back to the normal state.
So we set the text
color back to normal,
and we remove that
overlay we just added.
All right.
So we're all set.
Our transition looks great.
We're all set.
Let's put it into
activity transition.
All right.
What does it look like?
Holy moly.
Did you do this?
All right.
No, no, OK.
Remember what happened-- what
Nick was saying about this.
The values are captured in
the destination activity.
And when the values are captured
in the destination activity,
text view doesn't
have the text size
of the source activity's text.
So it doesn't even
know that it was there.
It doesn't know what
that font size was.
So what we have to do is send
that along as extra data.
Now, the activity
transitions system
will send the basic
stuff for you.
It will send you position,
size, and image scale,
right, because those
are very common things.
And those are the things that
are built into the system.
Those transitions are
built into the system.
But the other stuff, anything
that you need to animate,
you're going to
send along, as well.
So we put those in
as intent extras.
That's easy enough.
And then we get that intent
extra in the target activity,
and we get the-- our font size.
And then we call this
SharedElementCallback.
The SharedElementCallback
is where
you put all the really
complex part of your activity
transition.
This is a callback that has lots
of extra stuff for you to hook
into, to do the little
tweaking that you need to do.
And during the start, what
we have to do, of course,
is capture the transition-- the
text size of the current text
view, and then set
it to the one that we
want it to be in the start.
And in the end, of course, we
have to reset the text size
back to what it was before.
Otherwise, you just animate
to the little tiny font
from the start.
So what happens now?
You end up with a
beautiful transition
from activity to activity.
Nice and smooth.
Now Nick's going to come back
and show this really awesome
transition that he made up.
You guys have to see this.
NICK: Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Awesome.
So that's been some
pretty cool transitions
we've looked at so far.
One of my favorite things
in the updated motion
guidelines in the materials
spec is this section
on transforming things.
If you haven't
seen this, I highly
recommend you check out
both this, as well as there
was an awesome session at I/O
on Wednesday by John [INAUDIBLE]
about the updated
motion guidelines.
This talk's about
material design,
about how things are, you
know, sheets of digital paper
and so on, and that they
can transform from one thing
to another.
This transition in
particular caught my eye,
which is transitioning--
transforming,
sorry-- a Floating Action
Button, this circular FAB,
into a different
sheet of material.
I thought this was
pretty cool, and I
wanted to use this in
an opensource app which
I built called Plaid.
And I wanted to
transform from this FAB
here into this
bottom sheet, which
is essentially a linear layout.
So unlike the
transitions we've looked
at so far, which are
pretty much acting
on the same kind of view--
so transitioning an image
view in one window to an
image view in another,
or a text view to a text view,
for example-- this is, like,
pretty different, right?
We're going to go from a
floating action button--
basically an image button-- to
a linear layout, essentially.
So how do we do that?
So it's really, really
important to remember,
as we've talked about before,
that everything happens
in the destination window, so
in the window with this kind
of bottom sheet here.
So as with most
animation things,
we do some tricks to make it
look like the one thing is
transforming into the other.
So what we do is, in
the destination window,
we use setTranslationXandY to
basically center the dialogue
on the-- the
coordinates of the FAB.
So where it started from.
Just TranslationXandY.
And then we use the
view overlay again.
So if you haven't
used the view overlay,
this is the ability
to add, like,
drawables on top of the view.
So we add a solid color
drawable, as well as
an icon on top of
the view, and locate
that it sits in the center.
And then we run some
animations on this entire view.
So first, we fade out
the color and the icon.
We run a circular
reveal animation.
So that applies a
circular clipping mask.
And we start from
the size of the FAB,
and then we animate
that clip mask out
to show the whole dialogue.
And at the same time, we
move along a curved path
using this motion thing.
So when we run all of those
animations at the same time,
you get this effect.
It looks like you're
transforming from the FAB
to the dialogue.
So do you want to see
how we build this?
All right.
Before we do, let's think
about what information
we need to build it.
So in order to build
this transition,
we need to know the
positions, like where the FAB
was to where the dialogue is.
We need to know the
color it's going to,
and the icon because,
as we've talked about,
what we keep hammering
on about, it all
happens in the
destination window.
So the sheet doesn't know
anything about the FAB, right?
So how do we get all
this information?
So the position is pretty easy.
As George said,
the position is one
of the few things that actually
does get passed through.
So we can just-- in the
captureStart and captureEnd
bounds, we do the same thing.
We just call
CaptureValues, and we
put those bounds into the
value-- transition values map.
And we'll get access to
those a bit later on.
So we have the bounds of
the FAB and the dialogue.
So for the color and
the icon, I basically
created a couple constructors
that you can use.
So just like views,
transitions can have--
can be inflated from XML.
So when we looked at
the XML transition sets
that Ben was showing
you before, you
can define your own transitions,
as we did with the text resize,
but you can also add
your own attributes.
So here's an example
where we're doing,
you know,
context.obtainStyledAttributes,
just as you would
in the custom view.
And you can define your own
declare [INAUDIBLE] stylables
and pull them out
of that attribute.
So we could pass in the color
and the icon free attributes.
Just a quick note.
We're setting the
path motion here.
So this is what we
talked about before,
adding a path motion to
control the path which
it's going to move along later.
And we'll come back to
using that in a second.
But as an alternative, I
also added a dynamic way
of determining this,
because there's actually
different entry points that
I have into this screen.
So I couldn't statically
declare in the details activity
what color and icon it
was going to come from,
because it can come
from multiple places
into that screen.
So I added a
constructor which will
pass in the color
and the icon to use.
And so we can do
the technique which
George talked about
earlier of using
intent extras to pass this
information to the details
activity.
But here's a pattern which
I found really helpful
for implementing this.
This isn't part of the
transitions API contract,
but it's just a
pattern I found useful.
So I added a static
method onto the transition
object itself called addExtras.
So you can call this
from the source activity,
from the activity
which has the FAB
and knows about the
icon and the color.
So pass in those things
in a static method,
and it will add them
to the extras for you.
And then a corresponding
setup method,
I call it, which you would call
from the destination activity,
so from the activity with the
bottom sheet, which will then
pull those activity-- those
parameters out to the intent
extra fields.
And then it will actually create
an instance of this transition
object which I
called FabTransform,
itself set the target,
and then set it
on the window as the
SharedElementEnter.
The reason I like
this pattern is
because it means it keeps
the keys and so on private
to the transition.
You don't have to worry
about exposing that.
It kind of keeps it
nicely encapsulated.
Notice here that we're using
setSharedEnterElementTransition.
But if you remember
from the animation,
it goes both from
the FAB to the sheet,
as well as animating
from the sheet back down.
So what that means is
the element-- sorry,
the shared enter transition was
going to get used on the return
transition, as well.
So bear that in mind.
It's going to become
important in a second.
Right.
So we have all the information.
We've created the
transition object itself.
How do we actually
create the animators
to run this transition,
to make it all happen?
First off, we grab
out the bounds
that we saved into the
transitions values map,
and hold onto those.
I then do something where
I just check basically
which of those is wider.
It's maybe not the most
sophisticated method,
but that's how I work out
if I'm going from the FAB
to the dialogue or from
the dialogue to the FAB.
I'll basically use
that Boolean later on
to set up the
appropriate animation.
So for example, if you're going
from the FAB to the sheet,
you do an expanding
circular view,
or if you're going from
the sheet to the FAB,
you do a contracting circular
reveal, or circular hide.
Don't know.
So next up, the view is
always the endValues.view.
So even though you're giving
the start values and the end
values, you're always acting
on the endValues.view.
And something that
took me a little while
to get my head around was
that that view is always
in the state that
it ends up in, which
is to say when we were going
from the FAB to the dialogue,
it was already laid out and
positioned in the dialogue's
position.
And then we reversed it by
setting those translations
and so forth to put it back
into the FAB's position, right.
So it was already
in its end state.
Well, the same is true
when I'm going back.
So what that means is,
when I'm about to do
the animation from the
dialogue back to the FAB,
the FAB is-- the
dialogue is actually
laid out like this, just in the
exact same bounds as the FAB.
And so what you need
to do is to manually
call Measure and Layout
onto the dialogue
in order to put it
back into the position
that you want to animate from.
So it may sound
counterintuitive at first
that you have to call
Layout and Measure yourself,
but it is just how the system
works, that it's already
in that same state.
It was easy for
us on the way in.
We have to do a little bit
more work on the way back.
And then I just want to
highlight the translation,
as well.
So this is how we
use that path motion.
So we set a path motion in
the constructor early on.
And here, I'm using one of the
overloads of ObjectAnimator,
which will actually animate
two properties at once.
So here, I'm animating
the TranslationXandY
of the dialogue.
And we get hold of
that path motion
again, and call getPath,
passing in the start x and y
and the end x and y.
And that will generate
the curved path
and animate the translation
along the curved path for us.
We do some more animators
for the circular reveal
and the fade and so on.
And we put them in
set and return that.
And that gives you
that entire animation.
So that's how it's done.
And this is all open
source, as well,
so there'll be a
link at the end.
You can go and
have a look if you
wanted to go into all
the nitty-gritty details.
GEORGE: That was awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So let's talk about
a few things that I
think you guys will
find really useful here.
Transition names.
Now, if you do things well
with transition names,
the system will work for you,
and that will help you a lot.
For example, we have an
animation here, a transition,
to go from this little guy to
a big-- [INAUDIBLE] big thing.
We want to do an activity
transition like that.
And what's happening in
our activity transition is,
of course, we call
MakeSceneTransitionAnimation.
And we have this view.
And we-- my view doesn't
have a transition name here.
Or-- please don't do this--
you call view.setTransitionName
right here in this call.
Don't do that, OK?
And I'll show you why.
We have our activity here.
We launch a new one.
And then we change the
orientation of the phone.
What happens now?
That's right.
Our activity gets
rebuilt. But further,
the thing underneath
it gets rebuilt, too.
So even if you called
view.setTransitionName,
you just lost that.
It's gone.
So now when the view
tries to come back,
it has no idea which
is the shared element.
The transition name
is used to identify
which-- you know, going from
the source to the target,
and so it can map those two.
And if it loses that transition
name, it won't know what to do.
You, of course, can fix
that up for it, if you want.
And we'll talk about
that a little bit later.
But the transition
name is your friend.
So in a system like this,
where you have a RecyclerView,
for example, when
you bind your view,
that's when you set
your transition name.
And it should be a unique name
that you have for that item.
And it can be a URL
or whatever you want.
It's fine.
As long as it's a
string that's unique.
Here, I bound it
to the position,
in my ViewHolder, of
position is unique.
Whatever.
Or-- and a little plug
for data bindingg-- you
can do it right in
the layout, too,
if you're using data binding.
That's awesome, by the way.
I know some guy
who works on that.
Let's talk about changing
the shared elements.
That means we have a
different shared element
than you originally thought.
Here, I have a
view-- an activity.
And it launches another one.
And then we scroll
in the detail view.
And when we go back, we want to
go back to a different shared
element, right?
Now, this transition
system, of course,
is going to try to go back to
the same one you had before.
We have to tell
it something else.
Step one.
When you launch the
activity, ask for which
shared element is coming back.
So you
startActivityForResult. OK?
Step two.
Before you go back,
set the result.
Tell it which shared element
is going to come back to you.
Here, I have an ID that I'm
going to send back as a result.
Step three.
In onActivityReenter,
not onActivityResult--
I've gotten bitten by this
just yesterday, I think was,
when I was writing a demo--
onActivityReenter, that's
a new thing just for
activity transitions here.
It will be called before the
shared element comes back.
And this is where you
can do some tweaking.
Here, I'm going to get the
data, get the shared element.
OK?
And that's going
to come back to me.
All that data is
coming back to me.
And then we can also call a
shared element exit callback,
set the SharedElementCallback
for the exit.
Now the exit is used
for the exiting,
and also for the reenter.
It's the same callback
used for both.
And this is where
we can switch up
our activity-- our
shared elements.
We can set our shared
element to whatever
we want in our view hierarchy.
So here, I've just--
I used that ID I just
had-- got before from
the onActivityReenter.
And I used it right
now for my share--
to change my shared element.
And now it works perfectly.
Let's talk about overlays.
Shared elements often
go into the overlay.
If it'll just go right into the
overlay, unless we specifically
tell it not to.
Now, the great
thing about this is
it's drawn on top of
everything, right,
because you don't want to
have your shared element drawn
underneath something
over there, right.
And it's also not
clipped by the parent.
And that's really important.
But the problem is, it's
drawn on top of everything.
And when it's drawn
on top of everything,
that's a little
bit of a problem.
And it's also not
clipped by the parent.
Sorry. [INAUDIBLE] All right.
NICK: Here's a
real example I had
of this issue, which
is, in the screen,
again from Plaid, when
you click on a list item,
I wanted to have this
expand and grow out.
So I wanted to have
a shared element
where the background
was actually
one of the shared elements.
So if you look at
this transition,
there's two shared
elements going on here.
There's an image going from
one position to the other,
but also the
background transitions
to give that growing effect.
So this is all well and good.
But if you were to use the
overlay to do the transition,
if you put the background
into the overlay,
it's going to be on top
of everything else, right.
So you get this horrible effect
where it kind of grows up
and you don't see any content,
and it snaps in, right.
That's not what we want.
We actually want the content
to be able to kind of come in
on top of the background.
So hopefully we can
control that, George.
GEORGE: Yeah, we can.
Well, all we have to do
to make the shared element
do something different
is tell it not to.
And so we just set this
value in your styles.
But you might end up with
a little bit of a problem.
I think it was you.
You did it, right?
No.
Well, the problem is this.
Let's see what's going on here.
The shared element
is, of course, popped
into the new activity.
And when that happens, it's
being clipped by its parent.
And it's only visible
when the shared element
slides into the parent view.
So what we can do, of course, is
tell the parent, don't clip it.
So you'd say, tell the
parent, say setClipChildren
to false, and also
setClipToPadding false,
as well.
Now this is-- might
cause you a little bit
of a problem with your drawing.
So be careful with this.
And also, it's a
performance issue.
You might consider doing this
only during your transition.
But you can't do it just
on the parent of the view
of the shared element.
You have to go all the way
up, because the grandparent
can also clip the child and
clip your shared element.
And that's no good.
The other option
is to do, as Nick
did in his-- is to put
it right into the root,
into the root of his
layout as a child of that.
And now it's not
going to be clipped
by anything, because
the root, of course,
owns the whole window.
It's fine.
All right.
Let's take a look at it now
that it has no clipping.
It comes in.
Instead of like a flash,
it comes in on top,
just like we want.
All right.
Ben.
BEN: Cool.
Whoop.
So as you may have seen, within
some of these transitions,
and in general, if you
work with transitions,
you also have access to
the window decorations.
That was basically a status
bar in the navigation bar
backgrounds.
So let's take a look
at what you can do
is you just say define
a slide transition.
And what will happen
with that is that it
slides all the content in.
We highlighted the
status bar here
to show you what's going on.
So it slides the
status bar in, as well.
But we actually don't
want to do this.
And as you can see on the
bottom, under navigation bar,
there's also Flash.
And the last moment of that, it
still-- it slides up, as well.
So in order to
avoid this, there's
a couple of ways
you can do this.
But what you want
to do is you want
to exclude both the status bar
background and the navigation
bar background.
So we provided IDs, as well
as transition names, for those
so you can work with them.
That is one of the ways
that you can do it.
Obviously, you can
do this not just
in XML, as we showed you
before, but also when
you do this within your
code, you basically just say,
on this transition,
exclude the target,
and set those values to true.
But you can also do something
a little bit more nifty.
You can add this to the
shared element transitions.
So you could have
recolors in there,
or just fade out
stuff when you want,
or fade them out within a
shared element transition.
This is-- in order to do this,
you basically go all the way up
in the view hierarchy.
You get the decor
view of your window.
Then, you find the views by ID.
You create the pairs.
This is the second way
you can create pairs.
So another-- it's another
way to calling that.
And then adding them
to the shared element
transition to actually
have the system being
aware of exactly that.
And then you get
the desired behavior
of no flashes, no
exploding or just
moving out of the way status bar
or navigation bar background.
And with that, we actually have
a little room for questions.
So you can start
lining up if you have
questions, about six minutes.
Thank you very much
for being here.
It's been a pleasure to talk
to you about transitions,
and we have open
source all the code
already for the samples
that we gave here.
So the new one, the one with
the images that we just showed,
is on [INAUDIBLE].
You definitely have to take a
look in Nick [? Butcher's ?]
Plaid app if you want to
go into the advanced things
on transitions.
There's also topeka out
there, and another sample
called ourstreets.
You can take-- we looked through
the training that we have,
and yeah.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]